[Music]
hi rob my name is seth and i'm from
rhode island and my question is little
something something i want to know
what's the most exciting thing that you
look forward to
every year to do for fun
hi rob this is mary from boston bye
so we had steph and mary were getting in
on there i like that the thing i look
forward to most every year
i think listen
maybe it sounds kind of
lame but but it's i i gotta say it's
it's christmas with my family i think i
really do i love the holidays i love
you know everybody getting together i'm
usually in the middle of of shooting my
season of whatever show that i happen to
be on or a movie or whatever so
i'm ready for the break
super super ready and then just you know
having my coffee or my non-alcoholic
beer or my cigar and the fire and the
dogs and the kids and
um i'm very into my one present i get
and i usually get one it's usually
really listen don't feel bad for me but
i like one
present as opposed to a bunch of
other whatever i already know what i'm
getting this year because my wife is
incapable of surprising me
she just like i got you your birthday
present i'm like it's july
um so i know what i'm getting by the way
that's why i'm looking forward to
christmas because i already know what
i'm getting
so um i'm going with christmas um and
thank you for calling the lowdown line
you